in an increasingly digital world  cooperation between intelligence  agencies has become vital we have Jerry  Bernstein from the NSA arriving shortly  [Music]  hi mom  [Music]  Jerry Joseph Harris so great to finally  meet here this is a creme filled  director of site security at GCHQ no way  I was expecting a guy will you be along  then providing he plays by the rules  what'd you learn babe I think we can  learn a lot from each other  especially from me do you have an update  on China it's a pretty breathtaking work  on that this is just taken from  Wikipedia right you had that here  answering yes or no why is your favorite  film the greatest showmen when was the  last long-term relationship you had Oh  me love me love me ground these are our  top six suspects I always think it must  be quite stressful being a terrorist no  you have to let go right  boom mic drop looks like I'm finally  rubbing you off rubbing off on you  you're rubbing off on me you wish  you